the gyro can experience well I seek the
advice of experts whenever possible and
what what I was seeing was that there
was a lot of weird misinformation and I
couldn't conflicting information a lot
of people saying don't worry and a lot
of people that were terrified I'm like
okay I got to talk to an expert and luck
yeah you were willing to sit down with
us and help us out well you know and the
other thing I think that you know I
maybe it's a function of age but you
know Straight Talk is so important today
you know you know I'm so tired of having
people say to me oh if you tell them the
stuff they're gonna panic can I say well
what's panic have you seen anybody
riding in the streets yet have you seen
cars turned over smash have you seen
people hurting themselves over this
issue they're concerned you know they
want legitimate information and so what
you need to do is just tell them the
truth and we have many experiences like
that a few years ago when I was at the
State Health her in Minnesota we had a
big outbreak of meningitis a type of
brain infection bacterial brain
infection a number of high school
students were very sick all of a sudden
one day they were in a hospital in this
community of 20-some thousand people
were on edge and so we had a big town
meeting several thousand people showed
up and I trust them and gave me
everything I knew about meningitis what
we're gonna do about it etc and then
towards the end of the talk I said and I
just need to let you know about one on
every seven cases of this dies and
people looking said why did you tell of
that and I said because they needed to
know it two days later one of them died
and you know what everybody in town was
terribly sad very emotional but they all
said we knew it we knew it you told it
we knew it right and then they got on
with dealing with it we vaccinated the
whole town twenty thousand people who
vaccinated in one weekend for this
bacterial meningitis but it was because
they had faith in us because we told
them the truth and we said what we know
and what we didn't know and so that's
what we need to do here we need to just
have straight talk don't tell him it's
mo risk that's like the hurricane okay
you know I would be really mad at you if
I thought you were a hurricane
forecaster and you knew this was coming
but you kept telling me oh it's low risk
don't worry about it right
yeah once it hit yeah so that's what we
need to do today is just say this is
going to be challenging and we're gonna
get through it though we are going to
get through it I hope this wakes people
up to the value of vaccines - there's so
many wack
out there that think that vaccines are
you know a scam or they're dangerous or
that's there's so many people out there
that won't vaccinate their children I
know and that's one you know one of your
best shows beater hotels yeah he's a
dear friend of mine he's a I do too he's
a dear friend of mine as you and you
know he is one of the champions out
there on this very issue I couldn't
agree with you more I think that's
really an important point that you know
we got to get this idea these vaccines
can be life-saving if we had one right
now think how different this situation
will being were in right now it would be
radically different but do you see the
measles making a comeback and directly
attributed to a lack of vaccines you
know what and it's not only the vaccines
themselves but it's the prioritization
of vaccines I mean well you know one of
the real tragic stories right now in
Africa is we are just finally bringing
to a close this outbreak of Ebola in the
Democratic public to the Congo far
northeast part of the Congo
you know 20-some thousand people have
died from this okay
bad been going on for almost two years
and everybody talks about that and I
understand why bola is a challenge but
you know that during that same time
period over 7,000 kids and that same
area have died from measles because
everybody was preoccupied trying to deal
with Ebola and in that those deaths were
totally preventable totally preventable
so yeah I mean I I think that's you know
I I have to say and you know this I'm
already on this show so I'm not trying
to thank you for what you do say about
vaccines because people listen to you
and we need every positive voice because
we have so many crazy voices out there
right now that are so paranoid and
delusional and they want it all to be a
conspiracy there's been an amazing
medical innovation in in human culture
and that's vaccines
it's amazing what it's done and have
there been adverse perfect effects on
people of course everything everything
that people do there's some people are
gonna react in a bad way it doesn't mean
it's not a positive thing and there's a
reason why the cases of polio are so
tiny there's a reason why smallpox went
away it's because of vaccines absolutely
and you know it what that's one of the
challenges you know
today between the the the anti science
misinformation that's out there but then
when they don't see it yes and the
reason they don't see it is because we
did vaccinate until we get enough people
not vaccinated and then look what
happened there's a famous photo of two
twins from the early 20th century one of
them has smallpox and one of them was
vaccinated have you seen that I have I
have I have it's alive to my photo very
telling Jamie you'll find it because
it's people need to see it that that
that is the depth there is right there
that's it right there that's the one kid
whose body is just devastated by what
looks like he's like pebbles glued to
his skin all over his body's face his
hands and then the his brother right
next to them with nothing and you know
what's really important to note here is
is that in that body all those things
are very painful but what's going on
inside the body is equally bad yeah and
so you're exactly right I couldn't agree
with you more that you know this is this
is really an important point it diseases
are terrifying they're really terrifying
yeah and when something like this can be
prevented and the reason why people
don't do it is because they're paranoid
of vaccines and they get that
information from some wacko web site or
some person who really has no business
talking about it you know whether it's
the people out there that think it
causes diseases or that it's a
government plot or that it's a medical
scam is just trying to raise raise money
it's just all that all of its very very
disturbing but it's a part of people you
know the human beings for whatever
reason there's a percentage of us that
lean towards conspiratorial thinking and
they lean towards thinking that there's
some sort of a plot against them the
governments against them and it's just
you've gotta listen to medical experts
you know it and I hope that if there's
any good to come out of this terrible
corona virus situation is that there's a
wake-up call if we'd had a vaccine for
those or one that even worked partially
yeah think how different we'd be and you
know what we got new other ones coming
like those we have to use our creative
imagination you know as I said in the in
the book I the chapter on corona virus
is the title is SARS and MERS a
harbinger of things to come
yeah I mean we don't we can use our
creative imagination to say we should be
funding these things almost like we pay
for our fire department imagine if we
had to go out and buy a fire truck and
when the 9-1-1 call came in yes we need
to do it now
[Applause]